EQUAL JUSTICE IS ABOUT TO BE
SERVED.
TICK-TOCK.
WHAT A BOOK THIS WAS FROM THE
BEGINNING.
THE RUSSIA HOAX.
AND AN INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER
SARAH CARTER.
LET'S START WITH YOU.
THE LEGAL ASPECTS OF THIS IS AS
CLEAR AS WHAT HAPPENED.
IT'S A SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE.
>> IT IS.
>> Sean: BUT A BETRAYAL OF THE
TRUST WE GAVE THEM.
>> AND BILL BARR IS
INVESTIGATING THE CONDUCT OF THE
FBI IN THIS RUSSIAN COLLUSION
HOAX.
HE KNOWS THAT THE PROCESS BY THE
FBI WAS CORRUPTED BY POLITICAL
BIAS.
JUST LOOK AT THE TEXT MESSAGES
FROM PETER STRZOK.
THEY ARE ANTI-TRUMP.
HE IS LEADING THE INVESTIGATION
OF TRUMP.
THERE WAS NEVER ANY CREDIBLE
EVIDENCE TO LAUNCH THE
INVESTIGATION.
LISA PAGE VERIFIED THAT IN HER
OWN TESTIMONY.
COMEY ADMITED IT.
THEN THEY MADE MATTERS WORSE.
THEY LIED TO FISA JUDGES TO
OBTAIN A WIRETAP WARRANT.
ALL OF THIS, I THINK WILLIAM
BARR WILL INVESTIGATE.
WHEN HE RECEIVES A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL, HE WILL READ THE
FACTS, EVIDENCE AND LAW WHICH
WILL INITIATE I BELIEVE A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION BY BARR.
>> Sean: ALL THAT JAMES BAKER
REVEALED THAT HILLARY CLINTON'S
BEHAVIOR WAS ALARMING AND
APPALLING AND WORSE.
HE WAS ARGUING TO INDICT HER.
THE TOP LAWYER OF THE FBI.
HE DIDN'T HAVE THE POWER TO
OVERTURN COMEY AND THIS BAND OF
CLINTON SUPPORTERS HERE.
>> THIS IS WHAT IS SO
INTERESTING.
THE MOST IMPORTANT POINT IS THAT
COMEY WENT OUT BEFORE THE PUBLIC
AND SAID NO REASONABLE
PROSECUTOR WOULD BRING CHARGES
AGAINST HILLARY CLINTON.
YET HIS GENERAL COUNCIL WAS
FIGHTING WITH THEM THROUGHOUT
THE WHOLE INVESTIGATION.
BASICALLY ARGUING THAT THIS WAS
GROSS NEGLIGENCE.
UP UNTIL THE LAST DAY.
THAT'S IN BAKER'S TESTIMONY.
WHEN HE CHANGED HIS MIND.
HE DIDN'T ANSWER AS TO WHY.
IT WAS AS IF HE SAID HE WAS
TALKED INTO IT.
AT THE LAST-MINUTE, HE DECIDED
TO CHANGE HIS MIND.
YOU COULD SEE HE WAS APPALLED BY
IT.
HE WAS DISGUSTED BY IT.
THE FACT THAT COMEY CAME OUT AND
MADE THAT STATEMENT SHOWS THAT
COMEY WAS DISHONEST FROM THE
BEGINNING.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM
BARR HAS A LOT ON HIS HANDS.
HE DOESN'T JUST HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE CROSS FIRE HURRICANE
INVESTIGATION WHICH IT STARTED
AT THE END OF JULY.
HE WILL BE LOOKING AT WHAT
HAPPENED BEFORE THAT.
WITH THE MOLE THAT WAS WORKING
FOR THE FBI WHO WAS IN LONDON
AND HIS CONTACTS WITH GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS AND HOW THAT ALL
UNFOLDED.
AND ALSO OF THE INFORMATION THAT
LEAKED OUT ON GENERAL FLYNN.
THIS IS VITALLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTANDING WHAT WAS GOING ON.
THERE FLYNN IS THE BIG MYSTERY
RIGHT HERE.
THE ANSWERS WILL COME FORWARD.
>> Sean: WHAT WE KNOW McCABE AND
COMEY BRAGGING ABOUT SETTING HIM
UP AND KNOWING THAT THE FBI
DIDN'T THINK HE LIED.
THE REST OF THE MEETING THEY
FOCUSSED ON THE MUELLER REPORT.
WELL, MAYBE, HE DID OBSTRUCT
JUSTICE.
ALL OF THE REQUESTS ARE COMING
OUT.
CRIMINAL REFERRALS BY NUNES.
BARR PLEDGING AN INVESTIGATION.
THE IGREPORT ON ISIS ABUSE.
RELEASE OF MORE CLOSED DOOR
TESTIMONY AND THE ISIS
APPLICATIONS AND GANG OF 8
MATERIALS AND THE UKRAINE
INCIDENT.
THAT'S ALL COMING.
THIS IS NO WAY THIS HOUSE OF
CARDS CAN STAND AT THIS POINT
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
>> IT HAS NO FOUNDATION.
IT'S COLLAPSING AROUND EVERYONE.
ONE BIG THING WE CAN'T FORGET IS
HOW THE SENIOR OFFICIAL IN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION PLAYD ED
INTO THIS.
LET'S NOT FORGET ABOUT JOHN
BRENNAN AND ABOUT JAMES CLAPPER
AND NOT JAMES COMEY.
WE NEED TO LOOK INTO ALL OF THIS
AND FIND OUT WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED.
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENED HERE WITH
SENIOR OFFICIALS WERE TRYING TO
COUP A SITTING PRESIDENT.
>> THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WAS
GIVING THE MARCHING ORDERS TO
THE FBI TO CLEAR HILLARY
CLINTON.
THEY CREATED A LEGAL STANDARD
THAT DOESN'T EXIST IN THE
STATUTE.
THAT WAS THE EXCUSE TO CLEAR
HER.
ON THE SAME DAY THAT COMEY
CLEARED HER, THAT'S WHEN THE
TRUMP RUSSIAN COLLUSION HOAX
BEGAN.
>> Sean: I APPLAUD BOTH OF YOU.
YOU ARE A BIG PART OF ALL OF